a major 20/20 story broke over the
weekend and the assessments of the story
could not be more different even within
the left so let's go through it I'll
give you both perspectives and then I'll
tell you what I think makes sense Bernie
Sanders has taken a first place lead in
a historically important poll out of
Iowa the first state to vote in the 2020
Democratic primary Pete Budaj edge had
taken the lead in Iowa back in November
Bernie Sanders has now surged ahead with
20% support in the Des Moines Register
CNN poll mayor Pete is at 16 Elizabeth
Warren now actually in second place at
17 so it's Bernie 20 Warren 17 mayor
Pete 16 Biden 15 this poll is considered
the gold standard by many Bernie is
leading in the poll that is a very good
sign for Bernie Sanders that he could go
onward and upward to the admitted Emma
Craddock nomination that's one view okay
there's another view which I'll present
and then we can discuss which is more
relevant the other view is hold on a
second half of Iowa caucus-goers are not
even fully committed yet to any
candidate at all Bernie has a slight
lead among the half that has decided and
in addition there's the importance of
Iowa friend of the show bill scher who
many of our progressive viewers love to
hate has a piece out and bill argues
Iowa matters less than ever in 2020 now
please remember I'm just the messenger
here I'm telling you what people are
saying on both sides and bill says the
proof that Iowa matters less than ever
is that candidates are spending less
time than ever in Iowa this time around
if you look at 2004 2008 bill says
candidates were spending huge amounts of
time in Iowa this time there's very
little attention being paid because
candidates don't really believe it
matters that much Biden hasn't been
there lately
Warren stops by on weekends Bernie is
spending this entire week elsewhere even
though this is the first primary and
it's coming up and what bill scher
argues is that the DNC did this on
purpose the DNC pushed up the primaries
after Iowa and New Hampshire Nevada and
South Carolina specifically to make
first two primaries matter less there's
also the issue that is a broader
question which is Iowa is so white it
tells us very little about what
Democrats are going to do nationally
when they vote so these are the two
sides this is such great news bernie is
going to get the nomination the other
side is Iowa's irrelevant
Bernie's wit leading within the margin
of error this doesn't matter what is the
truth about this number one Iowa does
matter less than many people are willing
to admit
Bernie being in first place in Iowa
though is a big deal because if the
question is can Bernie build momentum as
the primaries get rolling up winning the
first primary proving his viability
there's no better start to a primary
season than winning the first one so it
is important in terms of momentum Iowa
is a proof of concept for a campaign of
sorts even though the South Carolina
numbers are going to be way different
than Iowa regardless because
demographically South Carolina is so
very different so it's true Iowa's very
small it's followed up very quickly by
other primaries and it's not very
diverse so the real takeaway here and I
hope you know it it you get clicks by
taking some hot take that's an extreme
position on one side or the other the
takeaway is a boring one which is
there's no one statistic that tells us
the full story about an election I get
all these people who email me they say
David no one's talking about this the
biggest gain in favorability in the
first three primaries over the last
three months was Andrew yang that means
he's the guy who's going to win and the
best person to run against Trump and a
shoo-in for the nomination or I'll get
another one
if you look only at Paul's done on
weekends Bernie does best and weekend
polling is more reflective of who will
really vote I'm making that one up so
thus bernie is the guy there is no one
metric or poll or calculation that tells
us the whole real story there's a degree
of unpredictability here there's a
degree of incomplete information look at
2016 when we could say Hillary lost
because she didn't go to Wisconsin in
the last two months
Hillary lost because James called me did
that press conference about her
because people were furious that the DNC
helped her get the nomination and that
got enough people to stay home that
Trump won Russian interference made it
so that Hillary lost the stock market
performance in the two weeks before the
press all of these things arguably
matter and there's no one thing that we
can say explains what happened or tells
us what's going to happen in 2020 life
is just way more complex than these
analyses account for and so the takeaway
is Bernie is leading in Iowa and that's
the best thing for him compared to being
in second place or in third place or in
fourth place he can win he has a lot of
work to do
other states will go very differently
than Iowa but what's clear is that
anybody writing Bernie off at this point
and saying he cannot win is just not
operating in the world of fact and
that's the big takeaway now after the
break
corporate media's panicking about Bernie
leading in Iowa Donald Trump is
panicking about Bernie leading in Iowa
we'll deal with that after the break in
the meantime let me know what you think
by leaving a reply as a comment if
you're watching on youtube or send me a
tweet at D Pakman curious to hear what
people think